This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇特的现代世界中，培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《百分之二》。搜索数字2.percent，即可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利希。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一件铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we discuss and talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, welcome back to the podcast. I hope you all had a really lovely holidays, whether you were by yourself or with your family or with friends. Yeah, it's a beautiful summer. I know COVID's kind of ruining a lot of plans. So if that's what happened to you, I'm really sorry. Hopefully it picks up in the new year, not case-wise, but, you know, fun and emotionally wise. So today we're talking about a concept
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习Learn the Hard Way。你好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们讨论并探讨二十岁时的一些重大变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。你好，欢迎再次来到这个播客。希望大家都度过了一个非常愉快的假期，无论你是独自一人、与家人还是朋友在一起。是的，这是一个美丽的夏天。我知道新冠疫情在某种程度上毁了很多计划。所以如果这就是你的遭遇，我深表歉意。希望在新的一年里情况会好转，不是指病例方面，而是指乐趣和情感方面。所以今天我们要讨论一个概念
that we all kind of have to become familiar with in our 20s. Forgiveness. There's surprisingly a lot of research and insights into how our minds cope with forgiveness and the emotional reactions kind of surrounding it. And I think forgiveness is such a loaded word. It's been tossed around self-help circles for years. But I think little has been made of what the science behind forgiveness can teach us about our own lives. And there's also a lot of advice about how to process forgiveness and why a philosophy of forgiveness in our lives, a personal philosophy, is great for our well-being. It's good for our relationships and overall peace and satisfaction. And I think it's a process we have to become incredibly comfortable with in our
我们在二十多岁时都不得不熟悉的心理概念。宽容。令人惊讶的是，关于我们的心灵如何应对宽容以及围绕它的各种情绪反应，有很多研究和见解。我认为“宽容”是一个饱含意义的词。多年来，它一直在自助领域被到处提及。但我认为，很少有人探讨过宽容背后的科学能给我们自己的生活带来什么启示。同时，也有很多关于如何处理宽容的建议，以及为什么在生活中拥有宽容的哲学、一种个人哲学对我们的幸福感大有裨益。它对我们的关系、整体的平静和满足感都有好处。我认为这是一个我们必须在二十多岁时变得极其适应的过程。
20s. As we face wrongdoings, we face conflict and spites. We have a lot of interpersonal growth that maybe comes from people doing the wrong thing. So let's dig into all the needy-gritty psychology behind, letting go those feelings and thoughts of resentment and bitterness, anger, and the need for vengeance against people we believed have wronged us, including ourselves. forgiveness of others is kind of the main thing we often talk about, but forgiving yourself for things and mistakes you make in your 20s, of which we will all do, is equally as important. So let's really dive in and learn some more about what psychology can teach us about forgiveness.
当我们面对不公正的待遇、冲突和恶意时。我们许多人际关系的成长，可能正是源于人们做了错误的事情。因此，让我们深入探讨这一切背后的微观心理学，放下对那些被我们认为伤害了我们的人的怨恨、痛苦、愤怒和复仇的渴望的想法和情绪，包括我们自己。对别人的宽容往往是我们经常谈论的主要事情，但原谅自己在二十多岁时所做的事情和犯下的错误——我们所有人都难免会犯——也同样重要。因此，让我们深入探讨并了解更多心理学关于宽容的教益。
Forgiveness is so important in our lives. Inevitably, people are going to wrong us, they're going to hurt us. And we kind of have two decisions to make after that happens. Either we can hold onto it and let it build anger and upset inside of us, or we can possibly forgive and let some of that anger go. Before we kind of get into it, I think we just need to dive into a few caveats before we get started, because I think forgiveness is a very nuanced topic. It's not straightforward, and that really should be reflected throughout our discussion
宽容在我们生活中非常重要。难免有人会冤枉我们，伤害我们。在那之后，我们通常有两个决定要做。要么我们把它藏在心里，让愤怒和沮丧在内部滋生；要么我们试着宽容，释怀一部分愤怒。在我们深入探讨之前，我认为我们需要在开始前明确一些前提，因为我认为宽容是一个非常微妙的话题。它并非非黑即白，这一点应该在我们的讨论中得到体现。
and throughout some of the advice that psychology tends to give us. I think firstly there are some things that are unforgivable and that benchmark is totally subjective. If someone has hurt you or violated your boundaries in a way that you don't believe deserves grace, that is entirely your decision and you're not obligated to let go of those feelings of hurt for the sake of the other person. I think there are so many instances that we can all kind of think of where you probably shouldn't forgive someone you can try and move on but they might not deserve for you to have to process their actions in a way that kind of redeems them and i think as psychology would say forgiveness does not mean forgetting your memories of of a pain or a betrayal are not eradicated by any kind of process
以及心理学倾向于给我们的某些建议中。我认为首先有些事情是不可原谅的，而这个标准完全是主观的。如果有人以一种你认为不值得原谅的方式伤害了你或侵犯了你的界限，这完全是你的决定，为了对方的利益，你没有义务放下那些受伤的感觉。我想我们都能想到很多这样的例子，你可能不应该原谅某人，你可以试着向前看，但他们可能不值得你以某种救赎他们的方式去处理他们的行为，而且正如心理学所说，宽容并不意味着遗忘，你对痛苦或背叛的记忆不会因为你经历的任何过程而被抹去。
you go through especially not overnight um maybe not ever either but i think from my perspective forgiveness is never for the other person. Staying angry and resentful and vengeful, it kind of comes at a price. All those feelings can have a really detrimental impact on your physical and emotional health, as well as your relationships. That's why, at the end of the day, forgiveness is really for you. It allows you to have peace and to view another person's actions as a result of their past, of their decisions, their flaws, and not your own, which I believe is really,
你所经历的一切，尤其是不会在一夜之间消失，也许永远也不会消失，但从我的角度来看，宽容从来都不是为了对方。保持愤怒、怨恨和报复心理是有代价的。所有这些情绪都会对你的身心健康以及人际关系产生极大的负面影响。这就是为什么归根结底，宽容其实是为了你自己。它能让你获得平静，并将另一个人的行为视为他们过去、他们的决定和他们的缺点的结果，而不是你自己的问题，我认为这真的很。
freeing and this also applies to yourself in many ways in probably all the most important ways. If you hold on to feelings of resentment, maybe resentment against yourself and anger at yourself and you let yourself stew in that, you are allowing your actions or their actions if it's another person to continue to kind of live rent free in your mind and impact you when you can't be confident your actions are influencing them in the same way. You continue to hold the weight of their actions within you. And it's kind of like quite an unfair equation. I think you're the one who's suffering and it's kind of in some ways their fault. And that's why forgiveness is really kind of a personal responsibility and kind of something that has a lot more personal benefits
解放身心。在许多方面，这同样适用于你自己，甚至在所有最重要方面都是如此。如果你一直怀恨在心，也许是对自己的怨恨和对自己生气，并让自己沉浸其中，你就是在允许你的行为——如果是别人的话，就是他们的行为——继续不请自在地占据你的大脑，并在你无法确信你的行为正以同样的方式影响他们时继续对你产生影响。你继续在内心承载着他们行为的重量。这实在是一种很不公平的平衡。我认为受苦的是你，某种程度上这甚至是他们的错。这就是为什么宽容实际上是一种个人责任，它带来的个人好处要远大于对对方的好处。
than it is for the other person. It's not absolving that person of any guilt. It's allowing yourself to clean your mind of their wrongdoings. Okay, that little tangent out of the way. I think it was important to kind of clear that up because there are many instances. I'm sure we can all imagine somewhere. Forgiveness is not possible and that is completely okay. But let's talk about some of the times when it is. This is what psychology today has to say about the idea of letting go of those nasty feelings of resentment that so often come when someone wrongs you. Forgiveness is really the cornerstone of any relationship, romantic or otherwise. We assume people see life the same way that we see life. However, there are as many perceptions as there are people in this world, maybe even more.
它并不是免除那个人的任何罪责，而是允许你自己清理大脑中他们的不当行为。好了，题外话到此为止。我认为澄清这一点很重要，因为有很多情况。我相信我们都能想到某个例子。宽容是不可能的，这完全没有问题。但让我们谈谈那些可以做到的时候。这就是《今日心理学》对放下当某人伤害你时经常产生的那些讨厌的怨恨情绪这一想法的看法。宽容实际上是任何关系的基石，无论是恋爱关系还是其他关系。我们假设人们看待生活的方式与我们看待生活的方式相同。然而，这个世界上有多少人，就有多少种看法，甚至可能更多。
Our luck of understanding of other people's perceptions, that's what can create those gaps that lead to miscommunication and anger, animosity and emotional disconnection. However, our relationship with forgiveness can help kind of bridge those gaps to hopefully a better outcome. we can intellectualize forgiveness as long as we want, but it's a process that takes time. It takes a lot of time when betrayal and miscommunication inhibit our ability to forgive. It's okay to feel those feelings. Shock and anger often come before forgiveness. It's like the grief process and we must first deal with those hurt feelings before moving into forgiveness and let us respect that process, a process that can happen sometimes without
我们对他人看法的理解不足，正是这种差距导致了沟通不畅、愤怒、敌意和情感脱节。然而，我们与宽容的关系可以帮助缩小这些差距，从而有望带来更好的结果。我们可以把宽容理性化任意长的时间，但这是一个需要时间的过程。当背叛和沟通不畅抑制了我们的宽容能力时，需要花费大量时间。去感受这些情绪是没有问题的。震惊和愤怒往往发生在宽容之前。这就像是悲伤的过程，在走向宽容之前，我们必须首先处理这些受伤的情绪，让我们尊重这个过程，这个有时甚至无需我们察觉就会发生的过程。
us even realizing it, sometimes by simply exploring the situation and in acknowledging the impact of the betrayal, the reasons and the context behind the betrayal, that can be the kind of beginning foundation of future peace, maybe forgiveness, maybe giving some people grace, understanding that their actions might not reflect the best parts of their character. But if you're finding forgiving someone hard, there's this idea in psychology called radical responsibility. And I kind of to really geek out about this because it was the philosophy that I intentionally adopted at the end of 2019 and it helped me immensely. I talk about this all the time. I think it is one of the best contributions of positive psychology ever. So radical responsibility, it kind of requires being accountable
有时只需探索情况并承认背叛的影响、背叛背后的原因和背景，这就可以成为未来平静的基石，也许是宽容，也许是给予某些人恩典，理解他们的行为可能并不反映他们品格中最好的一部分。但如果你发现原谅某人很困难，心理学上有一个概念叫做激进责任。我之所以对此感到十分着迷，是因为这是我在2019年底刻意采用的哲学，它对我帮助极大。我一直在谈论这个。我认为这是积极心理学有史以来最好的贡献之一。因此，激进责任要求你对自己负责。
for yourself, owning your actions, owning your feelings, thoughts and behaviors. And it involves voluntarily embracing a hundred percent of responsibility or ownership for each and every circumstance we face in life, day in, day out. This has nothing to do with self-blame. I think it's often misconstrued as making yourself accountable means making yourself feel bad, you know, nor is it kind of about heroically taking on some burden of some kind, making you, you know, meaning that you're a better person than others because you're more responsible for your actions, you're more radical and how you take accountability. It's just kind of an act of self-empowerment,
对你自己负责，对你的行为、感受、想法和行为负责。它包括自愿承担我们在生活中日复一日面临的每一个环境的百分之百的责任或所有权。这与自责毫无关系。我认为它经常被误解为让自己承担责任意味着让自己感觉不好，你知道，它也不是关于英雄般地承担某种负担，让你（你知道）意味着你是一个比其他人更好的人，因为你对自己的行为更负责任，你在承担责任时更加激进。它只是一种赋权的行为。
choosing to focus our available time and energy where we actually have influence. And that's completely ourselves and our choices. We cannot influence people to the degree that we sometimes want. But I think one way to make yourself feel better is that you can influence yourself. You have complete autonomy,
选择将我们可用的时间和精力集中在我们确实有影响力的领域。那就是完全是我们自己和我们的选择。我们无法像有时所希望的那样去影响别人。但我认为让自己感觉更好的一种方法是你可以影响你自己。你拥有完全的自主权，
although that's kind of up for debate, but you do have autonomy overwork. what you choose to do in a situation. And rather than reacting with fear, running away or denying that you have any power over what is happening, you kind of have to take the action to avoid reoccurring harmful behavior, either done by yourself or done against you by others. And you have to recognize behaviors that are unhealthy without judgment, without blame, and take responsibility for that.
虽然这还有待商榷，但你确实对你在某种情况下选择做什么拥有自主权。与其用恐惧做出反应、逃跑或否认你对正在发生的事情有任何权力，你不如采取行动去避免再次发生有害的行为，无论是你自己做的，还是别人对你做的。你必须毫无评判、毫无指责地识别不健康的的行为，并为此承担责任。
Okay, so how does radical responsibility to relate to forgiveness? because I know it kind of seems a little bit out there. Well, I'll tell you. I think it kind of relates in two ways. Firstly, you can recognize how we all make mistakes with radical responsibility. If you can accept that we all have ownership over our own actions, you can understand that you may have made the same mistakes that you're upset about with someone else
好吧，那么激进责任与宽容有什么关系呢？因为我知道这听合起来可能有点离谱。好吧，我来告诉你。我认为它在两个方面有关联。首先，你可以通过激进责任认识到我们都会犯错。如果你能接受我们都对自己的行为拥有所有权，你就会明白你可能也犯过让你对别人感到生气的同样的错误。
because it's completely, it's all on us. At every point, we have. to take ownership of our actions and I think it allows you to think about whether you would like to be forgiven if you made the same mistakes. That's something that I really, really think about when I'm facing a situation where either I've done someone wrong or I felt like betrayed, I felt hurt. Would I want to be forgiven if I had done the same thing? Can I understand why someone would have acted in that way, how my own actions may have created the situation that. it's forced them to feel like the only option is to just kind of borrow in deeper,
因为这完全取决于我们自己。在每一个节点上，我们都必须对自己的行为负责，我认为这能让你思考，如果你犯了同样的错误，你是否希望被原谅。每当我面对自己做错了事，或者感到被背叛、受到伤害的情况时，我真的、真的会思考这个问题。如果我做了同样的事情，我希望被原谅吗？我能理解为什么有人会那样做吗？我自己的行为是如何造成这种局面的？这迫使他们觉得唯一的选择就是挖掘得更深，
to kind of end up hurting someone. Radical responsibility, it also involves self-forgiveness, recognizing how your own mistakes are something that can be forgiven because you can take responsibility for your actions, but also allow yourself to see what's caused them. I think radical responsibility is also a skill that helps propel a forgiving attitude, but also one of removal. If a person has wronged you, radical responsibility allows you to forgive them,
最终导致伤害了别人。激进责任还涉及自我原谅，认识到你自己的错误是可以被原谅的，因为你可以对自己的行为负责，同时也允许自己看到是什么导致了这些错误。我认为激进责任也是一种有助于推动宽容态度的技能，但也是一种摆脱的技能。如果有人冤枉了你，激进责任不仅能让你原谅他们，还能让你认识到，你有责任把事情安排好，建立界限，制定策略，以确保你拥有所需的距离，确保这种事不再发生，或者如果它再次发生，你已经准备好面对后果，因为确保你在生活中获得最好的结果是你的责任，而且只能是你的责任。激进责任是整个技能工具包中的一项技能，它可以帮助我们原谅别人以及我们自己。这只是第一步，还有很多其他的步骤，很多同样重要并真正在整个心理学领域（不仅仅是在宽容领域）得到大力推广的其他步骤。所以第一步包括接受。当有人
but also recognize it's your responsibility to put things in place, to put boundaries in place, strategies in place to ensure that you have the distance you need, or it never happens again, or you're prepared with the consequences if it does because it's your responsibility, only yours to ensure that you get the best outcome in your life. Radical responsibility is kind of one skill within a whole skill toolkit that can assist us in forgiving others as well as ourselves. It's just one step and there are a bunch of others, a bunch of others that have been included that are equally as important and really, really promoted in psychology at large, not just in the area of forgiveness. So the first one includes acceptance. When someone
同时也要认识到，你有责任建立事物、设立边界、制定策略，以确保你拥有所需的距离，或者确保这种事情不再发生，或者如果再次发生时你已准备好承担后果，因为确保你在生活中获得最好结果是你的责任，也只能由你来承担。激进责任是整个技能工具包中的一种技能，它可以帮助我们原谅他人以及我们自己。这只是第一步，还有许多其他步骤，还有一堆其他步骤也被包含在内，它们同样重要，并且在整个心理学界得到了真正的、大力推广，而不仅仅局限于宽恕领域。所以第一步包括接纳。当有人
has done you wrong, acceptance is not about defeat or resignation. it's about accepting what has happened. You know, after all, while change is inevitable, suffering is the result of our resistance to it. It's the result of us not accepting another person's behavior, trying to excuse it, trying to create explanation, and acceptance kind of shifts the balance. Your view of what is happening alters.
对你做错了事，接纳并不是关于失败或认命，而是关于接受已经发生的事情。你知道，毕竟，改变是不可避免的，而痛苦则是我们抗拒改变的结果。这是我们不接受另一个人的行为、试图为之辩解、试图创造解释的结果，而接纳在某种程度上改变了平衡。你对正在发生的事情的看法发生了改变。
You separate the pain that is inevitable from the suffering that is optional. let me say that again. You separate the pain that is inevitable from the suffering that is optional. Pain and suffering are so different. Pain is this like instantaneous, spontaneous, emotional reaction,
你将不可避免的痛苦与可选的折磨区分开来。让我再说一遍。你将不可避免的痛苦与可选的折磨区分开来。痛苦和折磨是如此不同。痛苦就像是一种即时的、自发的、情绪反应，
but suffering is when you hold on to it. And to forgive, you must accept the past. That is not to say you like it or that you, you know, it was within your power to stop it, that you could have done something, but it's happened. And it can't be undone, but the suffering that you might feel
而折磨则是当你对它恋恋不舍的时候。要原谅，你必须接受过去。这并不是说你喜欢它，或者你觉得这在你的能力范围内是可以阻止的，或者你本可以做些什么，但它已经发生了。这是无法撤销的，但你可能感受到的痛苦
afterwards is completely optional. So the second kind of skill or step is emotional regulation. And emotional regulation helps you manage your emotions and avoid hijacking your amygdala. So that's the part of the brain responsible for initiating your flight or fight or fleeing, I guess, reaction. So research has shown that you cannot, you cannot suppress negative emotions. I'm sure we've all tried that. You've had a negative thought. You tried to just like shake it out of your brain or do something that distracts you, but it's always going to come back stronger. And it appears that you have, based on your behavior, your limbic system kind of tells a different story and remains highly active.
在事后完全是可选的。所以第二种技能或步骤是情绪调节。情绪调节可以帮助你管理情绪，避免劫持你的杏仁核。那是大脑中负责引发你的逃跑、战斗或逃离（我想是这样）反应的部分。研究表明，你不能、绝对不能压抑消极情绪。我确信我们都尝试过。你产生了一个消极的想法。你试图把它从大脑中摇晃出去，或者做点什么来转移注意力，但它总是会以更强的姿态卷土重来。而且从你的行为来看，你的边缘系统似乎讲述了一个不同的故事，并且仍然保持着高度活跃。
So like I said, even if you try, you can't really avoid feeling negative emotions. Instead, it's kind of better to become aware of your emotions and recognize and label them and interrupt and calm your response. You know, if you're saying, I feel tense, my heart is beating, faster, I'm scared. Naming emotions provides space and emotional regulation helps you identify and learn from your feelings. And this is really important for forgiveness where you need to be aware of the hurt, anger and grief you may be facing to accept it and to kind of move forward with grace and give yourself the peace that comes with forgiving and letting go. The third kind of skill is shifting
所以就像我说的，即使你努力尝试，你也无法真正避免感受到消极情绪。相反，更好的做法是意识到你的情绪，识别并给它们贴上标签，然后打断并平静你的反应。你知道，如果你在说，我感到紧张，我的心跳加快了，我很害怕。命名情绪可以提供空间，而情绪调节可以帮助你识别并从你的感受中学习。这对于原谅来说非常重要，你需要意识到你可能面临的伤害、愤怒和悲伤，以便接受它，并带着优雅继续前行，给自己带来原谅和放手所带来的平静。第三种技能是转换
perspectives. So shifting perspectives can help you stand back and observe your thoughts. observe your feelings and your bodily sensations and in that way you kind of cease to be a slave to a selfish narrative one that is trying to undermine you an awareness of the sensation is very different from experiencing it and it can provide the psychological distancing needed to move forward so psychological distancing this is a really important concept when we're talking about forgiveness it's about being able to view your emotional reactions view your pain, but not be too attached to it, not feel comfortable in it, which sometimes happens after a while. And it's the saying, you know, observing anger, it's not the same as
视角。因此，转换视角可以帮助你退后一步，观察你的想法。观察你的感受和身体感觉，通过这种方式，你不再是一个自私叙事的奴隶，不再是一个试图削弱你的叙事的奴隶。对感觉的觉察与体验这种感觉是截然不同的，它可以提供继续前行所需的心理距离。所以心理距离，在我们讨论宽恕时，这是一个非常重要的概念，它关乎能够审视你的情绪反应，审视你的痛苦，但又不会对其过于依恋，不会在其中感到舒适，而这种情况有时在一段时间后会发生。俗话说，观察愤怒并不等同于
being angry. There's a really great kind of strategy around that. It's always talked about in psychology. I'm sure if you have a therapist, they've suggested this, but it's called mindfulness, and it can kind of provide a practical path to shifting your perspective. And seeing that your experiences do not define who you are. I think mindfulness kind of has a bad rap because it's always kind of talked about in psychology and circles of psychological thought. But it's really useful. If you can sit back and observe your thoughts kind of floating through your head and not react to them, you'll find that you're a lot more prepared to deal with situations when those emotions are surprising. Okay, the next skill in the path and the journey to forgiveness is empathy and
生气。围绕这一点有一个非常棒的策略。心理学界经常讨论它。我敢肯定，如果你有心理治疗师，他们一定向你建议过这个，它被称为正念，它可以为转换你的视角提供一条切实的途径。并看到你的经历并不能定义你是谁。我认为正念的名声不太好，因为它总是在心理学和心理思想圈子里被讨论。但它真的很有用。如果你能坐下来观察你的想法在脑海中漂浮而不对它们做出反应，你会发现当这些情绪突然出现时，你会有更好的准备来应对各种情况。好了，通往宽恕之路上的下一个技能是同理心和
compassion. I know. It sounds so fucking bullshit. It sounds so wishy-washy. But empathy and compassion really helps you feel what another is experiencing and can be incredibly helpful on a path to forgiveness. If you can recognize why someone chose to act the way they did, it's really enlightening and it really helps you maybe, yeah, see things from their perspective, definitely. but also like I said with the radical responsibility things, it allows you to recognize how you could have made the same mistake. And while empathy is powerful at understanding the pain of another, compassion encourages you to take action needed to reduce that suffering.
同情心。我知道。听起来太他妈扯淡了。听起来太空洞了。但同理心和同情心确实能帮你感受到别人的体验，在通往宽恕的道路上会非常有帮助。如果你能认识到为什么某人会选择那样行事，这真的很有启发性，它确实能帮助你，是的，从他们的视角看待事物，绝对如此。但就像我在 radical responsibility（激进责任）中所说的那样，它能让你认识到你本可以犯下同样的错误。虽然同理心在理解他人的痛苦方面很强大，但同情心会鼓励你采取行动来减轻这种痛苦。
You know, they work in tandem, looking at someone, understanding their thoughts, their behavior, trying to put yourself in their shoes, maybe even thinking about their guilt, that is really, really important. And the final skill is, of course, radical responsibility, accepting your own role and moving forward. But of course, it's not always that simple and it's not just about skills, although they're important because I spent like five minutes talking about them.
你知道，它们是相辅相成的，看着某人，理解他们的想法、他们的行为，试着设身处地为他们着想，甚至考虑他们的内疚，这真的非常非常重要。最后的技能当然是激进责任，接受你自己的角色并继续前进。但当然，事情并不总是那么简单，也不仅仅关乎技能，尽管它们很重要，因为我花了大约五分钟来谈论它们。
There's also some proven steps to help along the process of forgiveness, and we'll talk about why it's important that you do so for your health later on. Although there are like a variety of definitions of forgiveness, research has suggested that they all kind of have three common components. Firstly, gaining a more balanced view of the offender and the event. Secondly, decreasing negative feelings towards the offender and potentially increasing compassion. And finally, giving up the right,
还有一些经过验证的步骤来帮助完成宽恕的过程，我们稍后会讨论为什么这样做对你的健康很重要。尽管宽恕有各种各样的定义，但研究表明它们都有三个共同的成分。首先，对加害者和事件获得更平衡的看法。其次，减少对加害者的负面情绪，并可能增加同情心。最后，放弃权利，
or the feeling that you have a right to punish the offender further or to demand restitution. That is such a big component. Forgiveness, I think, doesn't just involve being or accepting what's happened involves not needing to retaliate. It involves being free of the need to hurt someone the same way that they have hurt you, which is such a common reaction when you hate them when you're angry, wanting to just cause them the same pain that they've caused you.
或者觉得你有权利进一步惩罚加害者或要求赔偿。这是一个非常大的组成部分。宽恕，我认为，不仅仅涉及成为或接受已经发生的事情，还涉及不需要报复。它涉及摆脱以同样的方式去伤害那个曾伤害过你的人的需求，当你恨他们、当你愤怒时，这是一种非常常见的反应，想要给他们造成同样的痛苦。
You need to let that go because that becomes a very comfortable feeling to live in. A feeling of anger is very, very easy because it feels good, it's natural. but is it really going to give you the best outcome? Probably not. Simple steps, those three steps, really, when you say it like that. But I don't think it is that simple. You know, three simple steps makes it seem like that. But we know, we all know, anyone who has forgiven someone knows,
你需要放手，因为那会变成一种非常舒适的生活状态。愤怒的感觉非常非常容易，因为它感觉很好，很自然。但它真的能给你带来最好的结果吗？可能不会。简单的步骤，那三个步骤，当你这样说的时候确实如此。但我不认为事情就是那么简单。你知道，三个简单的步骤让它看起来很简单。但我们知道，我们都知道，任何原谅过别人的人都知道，
it's so much more consuming than that. It's so much more consuming than just being like, oh, yes, I give up my right to resent them. But when painful experiences do hit, sometimes we do need immediate strategies if you're feeling like that. vengeance, I guess. And one I find really useful is called positive emotion refocusing technique. So P-A-E-R-T, positive emotion refocusing technique, but I don't know why I said it, like, so, wow. So enthusiastically, but curtly. Anyhow, this technique can help in avoiding long-term pain
这要消耗更多的心力。这远比仅仅说“哦，是的，我放弃怨恨他们的权利”要消耗更多的心力。但当痛苦的经历真正来临时，如果你有那种感觉，有时我们确实需要即时的策略，我猜就是复仇。我发现其中一个非常有用，叫做积极情绪重新聚焦技术。也就是 P-A-E-R-T，积极情绪重新聚焦技术，但我不知道我为什么要说得这么……哇。如此热情，却又简短。无论如何，这项技术可以通过将你重新聚焦于当下，
by refocusing you in the moment, as the name kind of suggests, when we do feel overwhelmed by another person's actions or anger at ourselves or at that person. So PRT can be performed in less than a minute and pretty discreetly and it helps you kind of return to a state of calm. Importantly, it also helps you restore control and prepare yourself to make useful decisions. You know, don't act rashly when someone is hurt. You don't send angry messages. Don't try and undercut them or sabotage their relationships or something that's important to them. It just makes yourself the villain. So the way that you can kind of perform P-E-R-T when you're feeling like just overwhelmed by those feelings, just like aggression and anger, you find like a comfortable place to sit and
正如它的名字所暗示的那样，帮助避免长期痛苦，当我们确实感到被另一个人的行为、或者对我们自己或那个人的愤怒所压倒时。所以 PERT 可以在不到一分钟的时间内完成，而且相当隐蔽，它能帮助你恢复平静状态。重要的是，它还能帮助你恢复控制，并为你做出有用的决定做好准备。你知道，当有人受伤时，不要轻率行事。不要发送愤怒的信息。不要试图削弱他们或破坏他们的关系或对他们重要的事情。那只会把自己变成恶棍。所以当你被那些情绪，比如攻击和愤怒所压倒时，你可以通过以下方式来进行 PERT：找一个舒适的地方坐下来，
attend to each inhalation and exhalation, breathing essentially. On the third breath, focus on someone you love. Breathe gently, maintain focus, experiencing that emotion of of love deeply and wish on them every positive thing that you could possibly wish on. Maybe this is the person that has hurt you. If there's someone that was once close to you, remember why you loved them. Remember why you cared about them and wish good things upon them, not for yourself but for them so that maybe they don't hurt others, but maybe they're able to kind of push through the bad decisions they've made or, yeah, forgiving them, realizing why they would have done that.
关注每一次吸气和呼气，本质上就是呼吸。在第三次呼吸时，专注于你爱的人。轻柔地呼吸，保持专注，深深地体验那种爱的感情，并祝愿他们一切可能祝愿的积极事情。也许这个人就是伤害你的人。如果那是曾经与你亲近的人，记住你为什么爱他们。记住你为什么关心他们，并祝愿他们一切安好，不是为了你自己，而是为了他们，这样也许他们不会伤害其他人，或者也许他们能够挺过他们所做的不好的决定，或者，是的，原谅他们，意识到他们为什么会这样做。
maybe the guilt they're also feeling and ask yourself what you can do to overcome the difficulty you're experiencing in the present maybe you've seen them maybe you've received a message from them maybe someone's mentioned them just wish love upon them and i know it sounds so almost like christian i know that sounds weird but it sounds very like religious to wish love upon thy enemy but i've done it before it really works it really works to shift your mind frame And it's kind of nice to think that if you were in the position that they're in, maybe the person you've hurt would be doing the same thing, the same way that you would feel you deserve forgiveness, give them that grace. Throughout all of these skills and strategies, though, psychology tells us that forgiveness is a process like all other things and you cannot change your perspective or attitude towards someone overnight. And whilst the duration and difficulty will vary significantly, it can be equally applied to all levels of pain.
也许他们也感到了内疚，并问自己你能做些什么来克服你目前经历的困难。也许你见过他们，也许你收到了他们的信息，也许有人提到了他们，只要向他们送去爱。我知道这听起来几乎像是基督教风格，我知道这听起来很怪，但向你的敌人送去爱听起来确实很宗教化。但我以前做过，它真的管用。它确实能改变你的心态。而且想到如果你处于他们的位置，也许你伤害过的人也会做同样的事，就像你会觉得自己值得被原谅一样，给他们这种风度，这种感觉挺不错的。然而，贯穿所有这些技能和策略，心理学告诉我们，宽恕就像其他所有事情一样是一个过程，你不可能在一夜之间改变对某个人的看法或态度。虽然持续时间和难度会有很大差异，但它可以同样应用于各个程度的痛苦，
whether it's the result of someone being rude to us in a store, maybe a life cut short or a partner cheating, a friend lying to you. Yes, they're all going to evolve a certain level of pain. And it's important to realise that with time kind of heals most things. And both research and experience, I guess, have suggested that one roadblock people face with forgiveness is the idea of being seen as weak. and saying that what the offender did is excusable. But let's re-evaluate the definitions of forgiveness that we've kind of discussed. In many ways, I think it takes more strength to forgive. Staying angry and bitter is easy.
无论是由于某人在商店里对我们无礼、生命的夭折、伴侣出轨还是朋友对你撒谎。是的，它们都会引发一定程度的痛苦。重要的是要意识到时间能治愈大多数事情。研究和经验都表明，人们在面对宽恕时面临的一个路障是担心被视为软弱，并认为加害者所做的是可原谅的。但让我们重新评估我们所讨论的宽恕的定义。在许多方面，我认为原谅需要更多的力量。保持愤怒和痛苦很容易。
It's so easy because it feels good and it's comfortable. And we can accommodate and get used to our angry feelings because they feel, natural but it takes a lot more work to forgive someone it's not a natural instinct to move on it's not a natural instinct to see someone for their mistakes accept their mistakes and forgive them for those so to suggest i guess and for you to personally suggest in your own mind that forgiveness equals weakness i think is really false forgiveness is pretty powerful it's the harder path to choose now for some of the benefits i think throughout this I've kind of talked about why it's so good for your health, why you need to forgive people, why it's the best philosophy. I think a lot of people would say, well, why do
太容易了，因为感觉很好，很舒适。我们可以适应并习惯愤怒的情绪，因为它们感觉很自然，但原谅某人需要做更多的工作。继续前行不是一种本能，看到别人的错误、接受他们的错误并原谅他们的错误也不是一种本能。因此，我认为，如果你在自己心里暗示宽恕等于软弱，这真的是大错特错。宽恕是非常有力量的，这是更艰难的选择。现在谈谈一些好处，我想在整个过程中，我一直在谈论为什么它对你的健康这么好，为什么你需要原谅别人，为什么这是最好的哲学。我想很多人会说，好吧，为什么我
I need to do that? Why do I need to do that? Anger is just as a valid emotion as peace. It's okay to feel angry. Everyone's always saying that. It's okay to feel pain. Like all those emotions are equally as valid and important in how we operate as psychological beings, as beings with a consciousness. But for giving people, when it's, I guess, viable, has so many more benefits than anger. It has so many benefits psychologically. And I guess that's because anger is an emotion that inherently and innately heightens a lot of our reactions, heightens a lot of our physical states, and it puts pressure on your body. You can feel your anger. You can feel your pain. But when you have that kind of philosophy and that state of forgiveness, you can feel that peace as well.
需要这样做？为什么我需要这样做？愤怒和和平一样，是一种正当的情绪。感到愤怒是可以的。每个人都一直在这么说。感到痛苦是可以的。就像所有这些情绪一样，它们在我们作为心理生物、作为具有意识的生物的运作方式中同样有效且重要。但原谅别人，在可行的情况下，比愤怒有更多的好处。它在心理上有太多的好处。我想这是因为愤怒本身就是一种会增强我们许多反应、增强我们许多生理状态的情绪，它给你的身体带来了压力。你能感觉到你的愤怒。你能感觉到你的痛苦。但当你拥有那种哲学和宽恕的状态时，你也能感受到那种平静。
You can feel that your heart isn't working as hard, your mind isn't working as hard, your body isn't working as hard to push through those feelings of wanting vengeance. So there's this really cool professor, his name's Dr. Frederick Luskin. It's a director of the Stanford University Forgiveness Project. And the forgiveness project, I came across it maybe like five years ago, I think even when I was in high school. And it's a really cool initiative. So it started by this professor, and it gets people to share stories of forgiveness in order to kind of build hope, empathy, understanding, and self-forgiveness as well, not just forgiveness for others, which we typically think of.
你可以感觉到你的心脏不用跳得那么辛苦，你的大脑不用转得那么辛苦，你的身体不用那么费力地去压制那些想要报复的情绪。所以有一位非常酷的教授，他的名字叫 Dr. Frederick Luskin。他是斯坦福大学宽恕项目的总监。宽恕项目，我大约五年前偶然发现的，我想甚至在我上高中时就知道了。这是一个非常酷的倡议。它由这位教授发起，旨在让人们分享宽恕的故事，以建立希望、同理心、理解以及自我原谅，不仅仅是对他人的宽恕，这是我们通常会想到的。
And they're really, really interesting stories. There's one about this woman who forgives this man who basically, like, chopped off her limb during the Rwandan genocide, kind of puts things into perspective if she can forgive him for, mutilating her, acting in such violence. I think we can forgive like our neighbor for letting their dog shit on our lawn or something. So for one of his studies, this professor, he recruited students between 18 and 30 who wished to attend forgiveness training to resolve personal issues. Good on them. Very proud. So he split them into groups and he interviewed them before and after the training. And results confirmed really positively that forgiveness training helps people feel significant significantly less hurt, less stress.
这些是非常非常有趣的故事。有一个故事讲的是一个女人原谅了一个在卢旺达大屠杀期间几乎砍掉她肢体的男人，这让人对事情有了不同的看法，如果她能原谅他对她进行残害、表现出如此暴力，我想我们也可以原谅我们的邻居让他们的狗在我们的草坪上拉屎之类的。因此，为了他的其中一项研究，这位教授招募了 18 到 30 岁希望参加宽恕培训以解决个人问题的学生。真棒。非常骄傲。所以他把他们分成几组，并在培训前后对他们进行了采访。结果非常积极地证实，宽恕培训有助于人们显著减少受伤感、减少压力。
It helps them learn techniques for forgiving specific and more general resentment. And it also helps them release pain, release tension in their body, have more positive interpersonal relationships. And overall, the findings really suggested that learning to forgive improves psychological as well as physical wellness. And it offers protection against future upsets. It allows you to feel less hurt the next time someone does. you're wrong, put more healthy boundaries in place to maybe ensure that doesn't happen again,
它帮助他们学习原谅特定和更广泛怨恨的技术。它还帮助他们释放痛苦，释放身体的紧张，拥有更积极的人际关系。总的来说，研究结果确实表明，学习宽恕可以改善心理和身体健康。它提供了抵御未来烦恼的保护。它能让你在下次有人对你做错事时减少受伤感，建立更健康的界限以确保这种情况不再发生，
and it leads you to become emotionally stronger, it leads you to experience greater optimism, greater confidence, and I just think that sounds like a much better alternative than stewing in a pretty ugly emotion, stewing in stress and tension and vitroal. Psychology also says, and has shown time and time again that when people report a full philosophy of forgiveness or higher levels of forgiveness, they also tended to report better health habits and decreased depression, anxiety and anger levels, duh. Even in betrayed couples, so maybe couples where there's been cheating or something awful, greater levels of forgiveness were associated with more satisfied relationships, a stronger co-parenting alliance, and a child's perceptions
并引导你变得在情感上更坚强，引导你体验到更大的乐观、更多的自信，我只是觉得这听起来比沉溺于相当丑陋的情绪中、沉溺于压力、紧张和刻薄中要好得多。心理学还表明，并且一次又一次地证明，当人们报告完全的宽恕哲学或更高的宽恕水平时，他们往往也报告了更好的健康习惯，并且抑郁、焦虑和愤怒水平降低，废话。甚至在背叛的伴侣中，比如可能有出轨或其他可怕事情发生的伴侣，更高水平的宽恕与更满意的关系、更强大的共同抚养联盟以及孩子对父母功能的感知相关，
of parenting function. So it's better for your kids. Pass on those emotionally strong behaviors and you kind of see a healthy generational patterns and habits forming. Physologically, higher levels of forgiveness were associated with lower white blood cell count, lower blood pressure, and white blood cells are integral part of fighting diseases and infections. So obviously this makes sense because our psychological health is so integral to our health overall. But I still think that like the exact science is hard to pin down why forgiving people it means you have more white blood cells, which means you're better able to fight disease. I guess it's showing how our health is so holistic.
所以这对你的孩子更好。传递那些情绪坚强的行为，你会看到健康的代际模式和习惯正在形成。在生理上，更高水平的宽恕与较低的白细胞计数、较低的血压相关，而白细胞是抵抗疾病和感染不可或缺的一部分。所以这显然是有道理的，因为我们的心理健康对于我们的整体健康是如此不可或缺。但我仍然认为，确切的科学很难阐明为什么原谅别人意味着你有更多的白细胞，这意味着你更有能力抵抗疾病。我想这展示了我们的健康是多么的整体化。
It's not just about how much you exercise or how much mindfulness you do. It's all involved. It's all related. And I just think together these results highlight the importance of forgiveness. I know I sound like such a broken record, but it's not for the other person. It's for you. All those benefits are showing it's for you. You're the one who has more.
这不仅仅关乎你锻炼了多少或者你做了多少正念。这一切都牵涉其中。这一切都是相关的。我只是认为这些结果共同突显了宽恕的重要性。我知道我听起来像一张跳了针的唱片，但这并不是为了别人。这是为了你自己。所有这些好处都表明这是为了你自己。你是那个拥有更多
white blood cells, thank you very much. So don't allow your mind and your body, I guess, to go through another day of feeling vengeful and angry. You're the one who has to kind of hold that burden at the end of the day. Anyhow, like I said, broken record. We can talk about it all that we want, but I feel like we all know the best outcome. Or at least I seem to know. I seem to know what my personal philosophy is. If it's not your philosophy, I totally understand. And I also know there are so many instances where it's just not viable. You can't. forgive someone for some terrible wrongdoing and you shouldn't have to either but think if we see it as not for them but for you we kind of shift our perspectives and see life kind of in a better way
白细胞的人，非常感谢。所以，不要让你的心智和身体，我猜，再经历充满复仇和愤怒的一天。归根结底，你才是那个必须承担这种负担的人。无论如何，就像我说的，跳了针的唱片。我们可以随心所欲地谈论它，但我感觉我们都知道最好的结果。或者至少我似乎知道。我似乎知道我个人的哲学是什么。如果这不是你的哲学，我完全理解。而且我也知道有很多情况下这是不可行的。你不能原谅某人所做的可怕错事，你也不应该这样做。但想想如果我们把它看作不是为了他们而是为了你自己，我们就会改变我们的看法，并以更好的方式看待生活。
you can forgive people for anything really if you're willing to if you're able to and it really helps you doesn't help that other person they don't get to know you don't have to tell them that you've forgiven them just do it for you for you personally such an important thing as well for our 20s just because there's going to be so many instances in which people do hurt us. And it's kind of the first experience where it's a bit more complicated than just schoolyard antics. It's a lot more nuanced. There's so many different aspects to it. So being able to adopt that philosophy really does propel us into being better humans for the long run, better humans as we age.
如果你愿意、如果你能做到，其实你真的可以原谅别人所做的一切，这真的对你有帮助，并不是对另一个人有帮助，他们不需要知道，你也不必告诉他们你已经原谅了他们，只要为你自己这样做，对你个人而言，这对于我们的二十多岁来说也是一件非常重要的事情，只是因为会有很多别人伤害我们的情况。这也是第一次经历，它比单纯的校园恶作剧要复杂一些。它要微妙得多。里面有很多不同的方面。所以能够采纳这种哲学确实能推动我们在长期内成为更好的人，随着我们年龄的增长成为更好的人。
Thanks for listening to this episode. This was a suggestion by someone on Instagram. So thanks for engaging with the podcast on other platforms if you want to follow us on facebook on instagram wherever it's called 20s psychology podcast also Spotify and apple now allow you to leave reviews of podcasts wow crazy and a review sharing your feedback is probably the best and easiest way to help independent podcasters like myself who are doing this all on our own just out of the passion in our hearts. Really helps us grow. And, you know, every time I get like a new listener or a new follower on Instagram or on the podcast, a new subscriber, it really makes me really happy. So consider it a New Year's gift if you're willing to do it. It literally takes a second. And if
感谢收听本期节目。这是Instagram上某位听众的建议。所以感谢你在其他平台上与播客互动，如果你想在Facebook、Instagram上关注我们，无论它叫什么，它叫20s psychology podcast，而且Spotify和Apple现在也允许你对播客留下评论了，哇，太疯狂了，留下分享你反馈的评论可能是帮助像我这样完全靠自己、出于内心的热忱在做这件事的独立播客的最佳也是最简单的方法。这真的对我们的成长很有帮助。而且，你知道，每次我有一个新听众或Instagram上的新粉丝，或者播客上的新关注者、新订阅者，都真的让我非常开心。所以如果你愿意的话，就把这当作一份新年礼物吧。它真的只需要一秒钟。而且如果
you've gotten a something useful out of this podcast, I would of course really appreciate it. Also, another episode coming next week. Actually, two episodes. I've got Kate on. I've got Erin on. and Aaron's boyfriend, Jack, and the psychology of people-pleasing, a really good way to start your new year. So thanks all for the support this year, my first year in the podcast universe, and it's been amazing. So I love you all. And thank you for listening this far if you made it. Have a wonderful, wonderful day. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science.
你从这个播客中有所收获，我当然会非常感激。另外，下周还有一集节目。实际上是两集。我请来了凯特。我请来了埃伦。还有埃伦的男友杰克，探讨讨好型人格的心理学，这是开启新年的一种非常好的方式。所以感谢大家今年所有的支持，这是我进入播客世界的元年，它太棒了。所以我爱你们所有人。如果你坚持听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。祝你有美好、美好的一天。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%
of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app,
》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用上的TWA%
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick up. a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends,
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选。一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着弄清楚我们是如何在朋友们的陪伴下熬过那段日子的，
fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having a lot. honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行很多坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHard radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the hard way。这是一档IHart播客。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。